ouais j'ai trouvé de mieux que latapie
madison j'ai été un gros bruit l'homme a
tous moi je suis vraiment désolé attends
quoi n'a rien j'ai cru avoir vu quelque
chose mais mia tu veux essayer
mon dieu est témoin allez on essaie on
ne fait pas pipi dans les sacs à main
enfin tout du moins cela monsieur
faisait panne c'est la dernière chose
que son père lui a offert à leurs y est
très attaché il veut attirer l'attention
c'est évident voici notre fille rebecca
as tu vas leur répété mot pour mot ce
que je dirai je lis superbe pirouettes
et je voudrais te voir toi ton père a
acheté ce chat dans ma boutique
est-ce que tu le savais mais on s'en
fiche quand on doit traduire tu me
souviens qu'il a dit qu'il voulait
offrir exactement ce que tu lui avait
demandé l vieux chamane jetez pas fait
venir pour que du minium s'il vous plaît
madame vous pourriez nous laisser seuls
vous et le chant oui d'accord
et ouais j'ai aussi appris ta mère je
tenais à ce qu'on soit tous réunis ça
sent bon ici qu'est ce que ta cuisine
rotich a peut-être que sa chute l'a
rendu dans l'eau il est alcoolique il
refuse de manger mais j'ai retrouvé une
carafe vide d'un vieux mac callum
recouverte de poils en moi je souhaite
un choc j'ai du coup il a peut-être même
du whisky dans sa tête
est-ce que je peux m'installer dans un
bureau pas prêt pourquoi j'essaie de
trouver une solution pour ce problème de
autour de tours est ce qu'on fait d
irène pour chat tu veux dire un scanner
chaleur tas de l'humour maintenant et il
ya quelqu'un n'importe qui je suis
enfermé dans la peau d'un chat faut que
tu ailles km tu avoues la laver votre
horrible reste verte
alors est-ce que savannah temps le
cauchemar continue notre monde
non tu ne rêves pas vous mais je suis
l'homme qui murmure à l'oreille des
chats et je suis le seul à pouvoir
entendre
qu'est ce que vous m'avez fait je n'ai
rien fait du tout tu es tombé d'un toit
bien comment je sors de sa mauvaise
question la bonne c'est comment je suis
entré dans ce champ bien comment je suis
rentré dans sa c'est à toi de trouver
l'explication et il vaudrait mieux tu
arrives ça veut dire quoi ça donc on
n'est pas éternel et s'il vient expiré
tu restera coincé dans celui ci vont
nous restons tout à fait moi sortir de
la maison nous monsieur brand vous êtes
un chat ça n'a rien de dramatique mais
je déteste ça c'est bien pour ça que
c'est parfait le gourou cet homme
sortez moi de là c'est que quelques mots
écrits où est le problème
juste quelques mots rien de compliqué
où
appelé chair lara ne panique pas cet
homme il semble que je sois piégé dans
la peau d'un chat ce n'est pas une
blague
ton mari qui t'aiment top mois d'accord
c'est raté quoique